- How many owners have really come
out and spoke on our behalf?
How many of these college coaches have
come out and spoke on our behalf that
ride these Black players in football and
basketball to where they're the highest-paid
college coaches around the country and their
programs are benefiting? Not too many.
And to me, their silence speaks volumes.
- I'm Taylor Rooks.
And these are conversations about
defining one's relationship to Blackness
and how that defines their America.
So, when did you realize that being
Black was different than being white?
- I learned early. Being
biracial, born in San Jose,
I was, you know, as early as I can remember,
I was amongst Black and Mexican kids.
But I moved to Sacramento
at nine, eight or nine, and
I went from predominantly
Mexican and Black to all-white schools.
So in third grade, being new at
this school, I found out very early
on that I was Black, and it was because
the kids wouldn't let me play anything.
Couldn't play basketball with them,
wouldn’t let me play kickball with them,
wouldn’t let me throw the football with them.
And instead of, you know, poor me
hugging, consoled when I went home,
you know, my dad said, “If
they call you nigger, fight ‘em.”
So I learned in third grade that,
you know, if kids were—I didn't know
it was racial or racism at the time—but
if they called me nigger, cuz that's what
the kids were calling me, to fight ‘em.
So I learned fairly
early that my skin color
made some people just not
like me without even knowing me.
- How many fights did you get in?
- Oh, I got in so many fights that my
mom had to come work at my school.
And my mom came and worked as,
like, a yard duty on her off time at
my schools because it was constant.
And I would tell the school, and
nothing would really happen,
you know? So it got to a point where
my mom was just on campus during
the recess and during lunchtime,
just to kind of somewhat keep me out
of trouble but somewhat keep kids
away from me that were, you know, harassing me.
- In what ways do you feel like you
yourself were treated differently?
Maybe not by kids, but just by the
white people in the town that you lived.
- Um...
that I was just different, you know? Like
I said, my neighborhood was multicultural.
We had everything in my neighborhood,
but my parents early on made a point
to put me in better schools, and better
schools where I was from meant
white schools, you know? So I never
understood why. You know, I was so, like,
“Why can't I go to school with my friends in the
neighborhood?” and all that kind of stuff,
and I was never allowed to. And I guess
it set me up long-term to just kind of be
more versatile and more of a chameleon.
And even though, like I said, I'm
half-Italian, my first eight, nine years,
I was never really around
white kids, you know?
So to be thrust into that
position in
third grade
was a culture shock for me,
one, and then two, from the
educational side, I went from
being—going into third grade in San Jose,
moving and then being in third grade in
Sacramento. I got—and I realized what
the educational system was like too,
cuz I went from third grade there to
they had some of my classes
back in the kindergarten class.
So I'm this big old Billy Madison-type kid, bigger.
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- Because the schooling
where I was at was obviously below
par, you know? So I learned very
quickly at about age nine that
color and race played a huge factor in my life.
- You know, you've mentioned, you
know, being biracial, being half-Italian,
and there's obviously—you
know, Black people are not a monolith.
Everybody's experience is different,
just like everybody's DNA is different.
- Right.
- Not everybody's Blackness is the same.
Being half-white and being half-Black,
do you feel like you had to choose?
- I never chose.
And to be honest with you, I never
really fit in because as a biracial
child, you're never white enough
and you're never Black enough.
You know what I mean?
So I wasn't dark enough,
and I had this “good hair.”
And then with the white kids,
I was darker than them and
just a different complexion and different
mannerisms, you know? So I was never,
I never really had anywhere to run.
You know, now being biracial
is more of the norm.
And I think in the next 10
years, 15 years, everyone's
gonna be mixed up somewhat.
But I was really,
I was by myself. I was on an
island until I really got a chance.
And I think through sports, once
these kids, once they were finally
tired of getting beat up, they
finally allowed me to play with them.
And then once they allowed me to
play with them and I was the best at,
you know, football, basketball,
baseball, kickball. Through sports
is what allowed them to get the
chance to get to know me as a person.
So that was kind of the turning point.
And oddly enough, I still have friends from
third grade that, not necessarily that
I got into fights with, but that were
actually some of the first kids to kinda
accept me and allow me to kinda show who
I was through sports. And, man, almost 30
years later, you know, I'm still friends with them.
- Now, of course, you know, being Black
and white, you have lighter skin.
So I kinda want to talk to you about
colorism, not just in the Black community,
but how white people respond to colorism
or lighter-skinned Black people.
How do you think colorism
has maybe affected your life?
And have you seen people
respond to you differently
because you maybe have
more European features,
you have lighter skin?
- I don't think
colorism has affected me
as much as racism has. Racism has been
heavier, although colorism does exist.
And definitely, I feel like in our
Black community—and when I say
Black, I feel like these days, if
you have a drop of Black in you,
you're Black, you know what I mean?
So I learned at 17—um, 18, excuse
me—right before I was about to graduate
high school and go to UCLA in 1998, there
was a situation in my high school.
My sister was a sophomore, and a boy
was calling her nigger, spit in her hair,
and I never ran into this kid.
And finally, one day she came
to me as my fourth period ended.
I was going home for the day
and told me, “This boy called me
a nigger again and spit in my hair.”
So I went and happened to
just see the kid walking by.
So I did what a big brother does, you
know? Beat him up, tried to go to the
office and explain what happened,
and they didn't believe me.
So keeping this in mind, I'm
the No. 1 football player,
No. 1 basketball player.
Everyone knows I'm going to UCLA.
But here I'm in the midst of, you
know, kind of a racial situation where
my school doesn't believe me.
So to this day, I don't give a
dollar back to my high school
because of this particular incident.
So anyway, I get suspended for a
week, and while I'm suspended, my
school was vandalized by the KKK.
So, burnt down a bathroom, vandalized,
broken windows, swastikas everywhere,
“Die, nigger.” They had a mannequin hanging
from the big tree in front of my
school with my football jersey on
that said “Die, nigger.”
So, I realized at 17 or 18 that
even though I was very proud to be
biracial and Italian and Black, that
the world looked at me as a Black man.
So it wasn't, to answer your
other question, I never really
chose. The world chose for me.
- You said something I think is important,
which is, you know, “I was the No. 1
basketball player, No. 1
football player, but it didn't matter.”
Because I think a lot of times
when we are, you know, in the
heat of these racial movements,
people will say, “What do you know?
You're this, you're that. America has
afforded you these great things.
You don't even know what
it means to be, right,
like, to have, to be affected by racism”[a][b]
because that's not what your life
reflects. But they're not understanding
that whether you're a football player,
basketball player, famous person, you're
still Black at the end of the day.
- Absolutely.
- And I don't know if that is a
thing that registers. Like, racism
doesn't have to do with your status.
It's simply has to do
with the color of your skin.
- You know, having younger children,
I talked to them about that. And
my twins are half-Black, a
quarter-Italian and a quarter-Mexican,
you know, so they're very
mixed.
And I'm thankful from a standpoint of
everything I faced growing up that
you can't really tell what my kids are.
And like I said, in 2020, it's more of,
you know, biracial is around a
lot more than it was in the early ‘80s
when I was coming up as a child, because
it was, you know, you were Mexican, [c][d]you were Black,
you were white, you were Asian. There wasn't really
too much mixing going on at that time.
So, you know, I have conversations
with my sons cuz they're old
enough to understand stuff right now.
We talked about the George Floyd stuff
and simple stuff.
And, you know, one of my sons asked
me, like, “So, you're trying to tell me
that someone's gonna hate me just
cuz the color of my skin?”
And I said, “I hope not, but it's
definitely a possibility,” you know? So
for children to kind of grasp that, you
know? My kids aren't gonna grow up
like I grew up: food stamps, drug-filled
environment, abuse. Obviously, you know,
I've worked my butt off to put them
in private schools, and we live behind
gates. Myself and their mom live behind
gates, so they haven't experienced it.
And I hope they don't,
but I'm sure at one point
they will.
So I just kinda want
them to be prepared.
You know what I mean?
I think we have to start educating
our kids at an early age, knowing
that this is a, this is a cold world.
Although I feel now more than
ever, we're at a turning point,
with this stuff and
things are starting to get done.
I still really feel that that hate
will never go anywhere because it's
a taught trait, and there's still too
many people in this world that hate
and teach their children to hate.
So, you know, children
turn into adults that hate.
So,
I'm very open with my kids
when it comes to situations that they
need to be aware of, and race is
definitely one of them.
- When you're talking to your kids, how often do
you stress, or do you stress, that
for them to maybe succeed or be accepted,
they have to be excellent?
And the reason I ask that is because
I went into a talk where Lena Waithe was
discussing her movie Queen & Slim,
and there is a line in the
movie where he's talking about
how he wants to be the best.
And she says, “Why do Black people
always have to be excellent?”
And I think a lot of that is
because, like she said, we think
we have to be excellent in order to
justify the space that we take up.
Whereas, you know, I don't think white
people, the majority of white people, say
like, you know, “I have to be the best doctor.”
They can just be a doctor, you know?
Or “I have to be the best teacher.”
They can just—they are afforded the
luxury of not having to be exceptional
at it because they don't have to explain
to people why they are where they are.
- Well, I just think the reason why that
happens is because, you know, if we're
lucky enough to get into these fields
or these professions, we don't get
a chance to make mistakes, so to speak.
You know what I mean?
So a person, a white person, can be
very comfortable being a doctor,
lawyer, whatever the situation,
and if you mess up, you're most
likely gonna get another chance.
And I compare this really in
sports and with Black head coaches
having to really be careful picking
their jobs because most of the time
where there's a coaching
change, it’s because it's a bad team.
So a white coach can go in there and be
subpar and get fired and get another job.
But a Black coach, you know,
you don't get too many chances.
- I think white people historically
have been afforded the
opportunity to fail up.
- Right.
- And Black people just
do not get to fail up.
They only get to fail.
And more than that, it's like
when one Black person fails, it's
like all the Black people failed.
- Right.
- Yeah.
It's all completely,
completely grouped together.
But when you talk about, you know,
how certain, like, white coaches have
been able to bounce around, even if
they're losing, they get new jobs.
When we talk about diversity in
sports or diversity in any workplace,
it isn't simply so that you can
have these numbers to check off
that you have a person of color.
It actually really does improve the
place that you work, because maybe the
reason none of these teams are getting
better is because you're continuing
to hire the same people, and hiring
different people would improve it.
- You know,
so that's— know we can cross over.
We're just not getting the
opportunity to cross over.
-Yeah.
- But let me ask you—
- Yeah, go ahead.
- What is it like for for young, Black, coming up in a space
like this that has predominantly been
white women in your
position, or white men in your
position that are doing these, this
kind of stuff that you're doing?
- Yeah.
I mean, you know, I always say I
take a lot of pride in the fact that
I am a Black woman who looks Black.
And I say that because growing up,
when I was looking at any woman on
TV specifically covering sports,
they were white, blonde hair, and
if they weren't white or blonde
and they were Black,
they had
long hair, little noses, very light skin.
It was—everybody on TV was almost
tailored to make white people comfortable.
And I take a lot of pride and
responsibility in being in this space and
talking a lot about Black people, both
for Black people and to Black people.
Cuz I think it's important,
and I wish it's something that I
always had when I was growing up.
But my experience is always going
to be different than any man's, Black or white.
- Period.
- And definitely
different than any white woman.
But I find a lot of strength in that.
You know, I tell people all the time,
I think one of the biggest advantages
that I have as an interviewer is
that I'm a woman and that I am Black.
I think athletes just inherently
feel more comfortable talking
to someone who looks like them.
- Do you find that—
well, like you said, you found it to
be a strength, but can it also be a
negative point of view because one,
you're a woman in sports, and then
two, you're a Black woman in sports?
So although you've turned it into a
strength, was it ever a hindrance in
your process, or do you know any of your
colleagues who were in the same position
where it's held them back for those two
reasons that you’ve turned into strengths?
- Yeah, for sure.
I mean, you know, I'm very close with
Cari [Champion], I'm friends with Ros [Gold-Onwude], and
we talk about these
things all of the time.
I would say the hindrance hasn't
necessarily come from being Black as
much as it has come from the perception
of Black people or Black women.
I think
people oversexualize Black women.
- Mm.
- And they have, historically. It
doesn't matter what we're doing,
we become oversexualized.
And we are the only people that will
be talking to a person or doing an interview,
and somebody says, “Ooh, like,
they’d be cute together”
or “Ooh, are they dating?” simply because
we’re two Black people and a Black
woman. It doesn't matter what I wear.
I could be wearing a
turtleneck and slacks,
and the conversation is
about what I look like.
And that is because we
oversexualize Black women.
And I mean that about white men and
Black men. That is something that I think
Black men have to be a bit better at
is seeing Black women as whole
women and not just seeing them
and their relationship to them,
if that makes sense.
- I never thought about it from that point
of view. I've never looked at it and made
those assumptions. But, you know, being
friends with Cari, you know, these are
some of the conversations we have too.
And she tells me, you know, that “I'm
wearing a simple dress with my legs out,
and all of a sudden, I'm too sexy. But, you know,
my counterparts are wearing the same thing,
and just cuz she doesn't have
as much sun on her body,
it's not a problem.”
- Yeah.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
And I also think
it's so—that conversation is so
layered—but I think Black women are
left out of a lot of conversations.
And I think Breonna Taylor is a perfect
example of that, that she has been
lost in a lot of ways in this movement.
And I'm glad that now, you know,
everybody is calling for her murderers to
be arrested, and then you now have the
Breonna Law that was passed because of her, but—
- How do you have—me, what pisses me off,
not to cut you off, but
how do you have a law
for her now, but haven't
arrested the cops?
- That makes no sense.
- Those don't go together.
- Yeah, you're admitting there was some
type of wrongdoing.
- But you haven't arrested them.
- However, there's no consequence to the wrongdoers.
And I just think that's crazy.
- especially after seeing the police report,
which is insane, but go ahead.
- Yeah, no.
Yeah.
It's the Breonna Taylor thing is
just so sad and, you know, any
time I'm on my phone and I see, you
know, Black men dying, it hurts, but
to see someone who absolutely could
be you...like, Breonna Taylor is me.
She's my friend.
She is a Black woman who was working
and was just
in her apartment.
- Right.
- And I think that that hit a lot of us
differently, and I think Black women just
wanna continue to be supported the
way that Black women support Black men.
- I hear you.
I hear you.
- Cuz, like, nobody goes harder for Black men
than Black women.
- If you ever listen to Tupac’s song called "White
Man'z World" off the Makaveli album,
it says that, you know, Black
women are an endangered species.
So you guys have the
toughest job in this world,
you know what I mean?
To just, just exist, let
alone elevate yourself,
you know? Like I said, cuz
you're behind the eight ball twice.
- Yeah.
- You know, you're a woman, you're
Black, and don't be a lesbian.
You know what I mean?
So then all three things are
really stacked against you.
So I take pride in seeing women like
you and Cari and Lena and Ava [DuVernay] and
all these women, you know, exceed
expectations because although they're
killing us and doing all this stuff,
I still feel it's a lot harder for
Black women to climb the ladder,
so to speak, than it is
for Black men.
- Yeah.
No, I totally agree.
You touched on something in there
though that I wanna get your
opinion on. What do you think, or
how would you describe, is the Black
athlete’s relationship with the media?
- Um...
- Seeing it from you as an athlete and
now you as a media member that—
- I don’t want, because it's—I don't want it—
I'm not even gonna make that analogy
cuz it's not the right time.
They just don't trust ‘em.
You know what I mean?
And I think that's the reason why
myself and Stephen Jackson have been
able to succeed not only on ESPN and
Fox, but on our podcast, All the Smoke,
because there's no hidden agendas.
We're not looking for clickbait.
We genuinely wanna have
a conversation with you and
humanize you and show the world
the other side of you.
- You mentioned Jack,
and I just wanna give you a chance
to talk about maybe how you have
been moved by him during this time,
inspired by him during this time.
Cuz I think for so many of us,
it's just, it has been something in
this movement that has been beautiful,
and I think we've needed to hold on
to some things that are beautiful.
- Yes.
- And he's just, he's had
some really beautiful moments
that inspired us all.
- You know, just as a brother
of mine, I couldn't
have been more proud of him.
You know, Jack has kind of—
there was a misconception of who he was
because the brawl at, against Detroit
in the mid-2000s.
And I think he was labeled such
as, you know, as I was labeled
throughout my career, as a thug,
as a problem-maker,
you know, someone you
can't work with. But, you know,
our teammates would tell the world
everything but that. You know, we
were always labeled as great teammates.
They would always have our backs.
So to see his transition, one, shedding
his old image and reputation, but
then two, stepping into quote, unquote
the fire with this
George Floyd situation. Like
he said, it wasn't something he planned,
it wasn't something he wanted, but it
was something that was put on his plate.
And I think he's done a tremendous job of
handling what's come with that.
You know, I've been in this social justice
space for maybe about four or five years.
I did the Stephon Clark stuff up
north in Sacramento, my hometown.
And even though I'm doing stuff right
and speaking on the behalf of the people
who don't have a voice, you're still
gonna take a lot of criticism from people.
And, you know, that's something
that Jack is getting now, you
know? So we're talking here and there.
I know his plate is full, but, you know, I
just hit him every once in a while just to
remind the man of how proud I am of
him, how much I love him and to really
take care of himself, you know what I mean?
Cuz this, just all this negativity,
and I'm sure you’ve felt it too,
it just, it's disheartening, and
it sucks the life out of you.
You know what I mean?
And him to be on the front
line still in Minnesota
nearly two weeks later,
I just tell him, you know, to protect
his essence, protect his
mental health, make sure he gets rest,
make sure he's taking time for him
because, you know, all this negativity is
not good for anybody, you know? But he's
doing it for a great reason, but there's
still a lot of pushback, and you see a
lot of people talking negative about him
and his family now and calling him an
opportunist and all this kind of stuff
when at the end of the day,
he's doing what's right,
and he's a part,
and he's—when we look back on this
in 20 or 30 years, Jack is gonna be
one of the main people that people think
about as far as turning this movement.
You know, there's—obviously George
Floyd wasn't the first, and he won't
be the last, but I think for the first
time in 400 years, the world hears us.
And it's because this man was executed
in front of us and the world saw it.
- Yeah.
- So that was the tipping point finally.
And although I never, and you
probably feel the same way,
I didn't agree with the looting and
stealing stuff and burning stuff, but
at the same time, they've always had a
problem with every way we've protested.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
You gotta do what you gotta do at some point.
- We’ve protested silently. We’ve done marches.
Kap took a knee and was blackballed.
So, you know, enough was enough,
and there was some casualties of wars,
and that was small businesses and stuff.
But for the first time, they hear
us now, and I think Jack's platform
brought a lot of light to that.
And obviously there were the
Shaun Kings and other athletes
and other actors, but I think
Stephen's connection to George Floyd
made it that much more
special that he was a part of it and someone
that’s leading the movement forward.
- We talk about the movement, and
the movement is now touching
a lot of different areas.
I had just reported that I had
been talking to multiple NBA
players, and they said that
a couple days ago, there was
a call with about 50 of them
talking about what they could do.
And tonight, they plan on having
a call with a much larger number,
figuring out what they wanna do.
Have you been privy to those
calls, and what is kind of the chatter?
I know you talked a little
bit about it.
- I don't really know what's going
on in those conversations.
I've had conversations with a
couple guys that were kinda like,
“You know, do we play in the midst of
all this, in the midst of the pandemic?”
You know, but I really feel like
right now, more than ever, the Black
voice is heard, but the Black athlete
voice has never been stronger and
may never be stronger, you know?
So whatever they do, and
the athlete in me obviously
doesn't want to see them sit out.
I miss basketball as much as everyone
else does, as much as they do,
and I wanna see it get back to the
court. But at the same time, being able
to watch this Blackballed documentary of
my Clipper team from 2014, being
in the moment, obviously, as players and
feeling like we had a chance to win a
championship, we wanted to play because
we didn't know what the outcome of
sitting out was, but we also didn't know
the magnitude and the message it would
have sent if we did sit out, you know?
So I hope that everyone got a chance
to see that and kinda learn because
me looking at it six years ago,
removed, being six years removed,
I would’ve urged my team to sit out.
You know, I was the one that
came up with the idea of what
to do as far as the jerseys and
flip and all this kinda stuff.
And we did have conversations about not
playing, and Golden State was on board
with us as well, but we did—there
was too much unknown. But I think now
we're at a point where, like I said,
our voice has never been stronger.
Although I don't want them to sit,
I would understand if they sat out
a game or did something to really
let everyone know that this is not OK,
we're unified, and we need to be heard.
So, to get back to your point, I
haven't been on those conversations,
and I don't really pry. I'm
someone—I'm a quote, unquote OG now.
So people just randomly
reach out to me, kinda ask me
what I think and my thoughts.
So I have spoke to a few
players on that
front, and I don't preach. I
don't tell ‘em to sit out.
I just kind of give ‘em the whole
magnitude of the situation and
understanding “Whatever you guys do,
it's gonna be powerful.
So just make sure you're
united in that movement.”
- Mhmm.
What would you say to Adam Silver if
he asked you the best way to address
racism in the league?
- Ooh, that’s a good question.
I think all the teams should start a fund,
you know, and really, and
individual funds for their cities
and look to help their
communities, not just put out PSAs or
cheap PR things of guys saying stuff,
because, you know, how most of this stuff
goes is it’s talked about and then
a couple weeks later, we get back to
real life and kind of forget about it.
I would love to see each team
start some sort of fund that is
community-based in their city,
and it can go to a
number of different things.
Whatever that team feels is
lacking in their minority, in the
minority culture of their cities.
You know, I had a phone call with
Rob Pelinka maybe two weeks ago
out of the blue. And he kind of just hit
me up like, “Hey, Matt, you know, we're
looking for things to do as, as the
Lakers, you know, as a, as
an organization to really unite and be
a part of this movement and
be an effective part of this movement.”
And it kinda took me off guard.
I'm like, “The Lakers
are calling me to ask?”
I mean, so, I told them—I was
like, “Man, that's a heavy question.
I got Zooms.
I got my kids.
Give me till the end of the day
and I'll send you some ideas.”
So I sent him some ideas, but the first
thing—I said it earlier—it’s just like,
“This can't be just a PR move to save face.”
You know what I mean?
This can't just be, “Let me,
let me put a Lakers statement out,
let the Lakers know you're
with us.” To me, either
don't say nothing—
if you get in, you gotta really get in.
You gotta be entrenched.
There's things you can do.
And I gave him a list of things they
can do, and I'm gonna probably
talk to him this week to kind of
touch base and see what they decided.
But you know, to me, you gotta be all
the way in, and it’s seen that the NBA
is so progressive, and we usually are
the ones that are first to
do stuff and people follow.
I would just love to see each team
start a fund because, you know, these
organizations are making so much
money off these players, and although
the players have tremendous contracts,
you gotta think, if our
contracts are so well,
how much are the owners making?
You know, if they're able to pay
Steph and LeBron and these guys
$200 million a year—excuse me,
$200 million contracts—
imagine how much
money these teams are making.
So you start these funds and
consistently doing stuff.
Don't give me a one-time
donation. Make it, make it a—
- Make this a cornerstone of your franchise.
- Right.
- Make it a yearly thing, make it a once-a-year
huge donation, but let's
build something from here.
And that's what I was
trying to tell the Lakers is,
“If you guys do something
trendsetting or groundbreaking,
you guys are the Lakers.
So I think other teams are gonna fall
in line, not only in basketball, but
professional sports across the board.”
So,
it’s gonna be interesting.
I've always been a fan of Adam
Silver and his outside-the-box thinking.
But I think the NBA is so progressive,
it has to be something that's heartfelt,
that's meaningful,
that won't just go away,
you know, once we're done talking about
George Floyd.
- And you're right. The
NBA is so progressive, probably
the most progressive of the leagues.
I think Adam Silver is a
fantastic leader, and the things
that he has done for the league.
You, however, were in the thick
of a scandal with the league
when everybody found out that,
you know, Donald Sterling was racist.
- Right.
- But I guess, and I mean symbolically,
how many, if any, Donald Sterlings
still exist in NBA front offices?
- A lot.
A lot.
And not only in the NBA; in the NFL,
I know for sure.
You know what I mean?
So it's just, and I don't—you don't
wanna give names, but there's
that good ol’ boy group of owners that
were oil or real estate guys. These
guys are in there, you know, 70s,
late 60s, 70s and up.
And that's just how they were
raised and how they were brought up.
You know what I mean?
And they look at players as—I didn't
wanna use the word “slave,” that's
harsh—but just these are my, like—
a kind of a plantation view or mentality.
Like, “These are my guys.
I pay them.”
Like Donald Sterling
said, “I get them cars.
I get them food.
I get them houses.” But he wasn't
the only one to think like that.
He's just the only one dumb enough
to get caught, but I guarantee
there's owners in these leagues
and, in particular, if you look at it, how
many owners have really came out and spoke
on behalf of us? And not a generic—like
Roger Goodell read off the thing and still
didn’t even address the Kap situation.
But how many owners have really
come out and spoke on our behalf?
How many of these college coaches have
come out and spoke on our behalf that
ride these Black players in football and
basketball to where they're the highest-paid
college coaches around the country and their
programs are benefiting? Not too many.
And to me, their silence speaks volumes.
You know what I mean?
You wanna go into our house
as college players and “I'm
gonna take care of your son
I'm gonna do whatever.
He's gonna love it in Lexington.”
And “He's gonna love it in Oklahoma,”
or “He's gonna love it at LSU.”
But now when when the, you know,
the shit quote, unquote really hits
the fan, you're getting these generic,
you know, statements that PR people wrote
for these coaches to read, and I just wish
it would be more heartfelt and you had
that same energy when you're trying to
recruit us to win national championships
now that you have for us
when our backs are against the
wall and we're in this fire.
- Yeah.
And—I'm not asking you to name
names—when I asked you the
question, you said, “For sure.”
Are there, like, instances in your head
that make you sure, you know, that there
are these people that still exist?
- Yes.
I've seen situations that have
happened personally to me.
I've been around other owners.
I've played for several teams.
I've talked to different
players about situations,
and not only in basketball,
in football, and it's just kind
of an unspoken thing, you know,
but it's definitely still there.
It's definitely prevalent.
And, you know, I think the fact that
they had to make the Rooney Rule in the
NFL, which is crazy to think that you
had to make a rule that teams would
at least interview one minority person
for management jobs tells you their
train of thought and the lines
of their thinking, because most of
the time they're just looking over
us or not even giving us
an opportunity, you know, for those.
So some people say, you know,
“Those jobs aren't racially filled.
It's just the best man gets the job.”
And for the most part, that's true,
but the best Black candidates
aren't even getting a chance.
- Yeah.
- The best minority candidates aren’t even getting a
chance to interview, you know? So I'm sure you
probably hired the best white person
you felt fit the job, but it's because
you didn't give any Black people a
chance to even interview for the job.
- I was watching an interview
that you did with Vlad,
and you had this quote. You said,
"To me, there will always be racism.
Racism is something that's taught.
We have to learn to maneuver within that."
So my question, is that what you still
believe, and if so, how do we win
If racism will always exist?
- I think it's always gonna exist,
and I still do agree with that.
But I think we're to a point now where
we need more white allies, and
we're starting to gain those.
And I think the one thing we saw
through these protests and rallies and
riots, whatever you wanna call it,
we had every race out there.
You know, every skin color,
every religion, everyone came
together, you know what I mean?
So I think we need more people that
are for us and with us
and have an open mind to the task.
Cuz we used to give people a pass
saying, “Well, you know, they didn't grow
up that way, or “They're white,” or
and “That's why they don't understand this.”
And that used to be an
OK pass that people get.
But now it's not OK.
You know, now you have to have
an understanding, and I think
people are starting to do that.
So,
I just feel like we need
to call people on racism.
People need to be fired from their jobs.
People need to be publicly embarrassed.
The world needs to know that, you know,
your FedEx driver that is delivering
your packages, you know, did a protest
the other day with a man, a knee on a
man's neck talking about, you know, “Eff
George Floyd. Black lives don't matter.
Only white lives matter.”
You know?
So I think more than ever, you know,
the Black culture quote, unquote wants
to be on this cancel culture.
But to be
honest with you, this cancel culture
now more than ever is gonna be
real because we're getting people
on camera who are just blatantly
showing who they are and their racism.
And before you know it,
their face is circling and their name’s
circling, and then they're fired.
You know?
So when I say I think we're
gonna have to work within that,
I think we just need to
continue to have that,
you know, we always got criticized.
“Oh, you always wanna bring race in it. Why do
you always wanna pull the race card?” Cuz race
plays a big part in our everyday lives.
- In everything.
- And people finally see that now.
So, like I said, it's a taught thing.
Hopefully it's gonna open
up enough eyes for parents to
start teaching love because your kid is
gonna, you know—like, I had a conversation
with my twins about the George Floyd
situation, and I asked them, “Is hate taught,
or are you born with it?”
And they both hesitated,
and they're like, “Taught.” I'm like,
“You're absolutely right.
Like, just like you can teach love.”
And then they have a—I
have an 18-month-old too.
So then one of my sons is like, “We're
gonna have to teach Ashton how to love,”
you know? And it's really that
simple, you know what I mean?
These kids are sponges, so
they're gonna, they're gonna
learn and be whatever you feed them, you
know? So if you're teaching them love,
they're gonna have a better chance.
So, like I said, I still think
there's too many people in this
world that hate for no reason.
If you asked to a KKK member
or a white person, like, “Why
don't you like Black people?”
They couldn't give you no real answer.
- Mhmm.
- They're gonna give you
a stereotypical answer.
“One of them robbed my cousin,” or “They
do this,” or “They're on welfare.”
They can't give you no real answers.
So they're just hating
to hate.
So I hope this movement changes some
of that, but I'm not naive enough to
think it's just gonna disappear.
So I think we're just gonna have
to learn to maneuver within it, but
more white people are gonna have
to start calling people on this stuff.
Just like bad cops are gonna start
having to call bad cops on their stuff.
I just think the more we expose
this hate, it’ll eventually,
you know, not go away,
but hopefully shrink.
- I'm ending every interview in
this series with this question,
and that's that words mean different
things to different people.
Matt, how do you define
America?
- A gift and a curse.
I think that we're very lucky in
some aspects to be here and, and
live this quote, unquote dream, because
although it's been tough for me,
I've been able to live a dream.
I’ve faced a ton of racism in my 40
years, but if I sit back and look at
the big picture, I played 14 years
in the NBA, made a lot of money,
have a beautiful family, and I'm
thriving in business and doing
things to try to help other people.
But at the same time, I was the lucky one,
you know? We both beat the odds to
be able to do what you're doing,
to be able to do what I'm doing.
We beat the odds.
So we realized that some of
our people aren't as lucky.
And that's where I say it's a curse
because I've had personal friends,
and we've seen people that we don't
even know but have grown fond of, lose their
life because of the color of their skin.
So it definitely means, the flag means
something different to most Black people.
America means something
different to most Black people.
But I think at the end of the
day, we are lucky to an extent.
And I think now more than ever, our voices
are gonna be heard, and we have a chance
to change what America means and what
that flag means for our children, our
grandchildren and generations to come.
- That was beautiful.
Thank you so much, Matt.
- No problem.
Thanks for having me.
Good luck.